hello everybody my name is markip and
welcome to Techie techie moonlit dread I
don't know who that is and I don't know
why they're there but I have a funny
feeling that they need help judging by
all the blood so I'm going to go help
them hi Oh I thought it was going to
beat I thought that I was going to
actually go into the game right then and
there but I
didn't oh done oh hi what is
this read mysterious brutal incident man
found cut in half with no
clues
aikawa Japan a man was found with his
body cut in half near the stationary of
asahikawa city in a shocking incident
that has baffled the police the crime
scene was discovered by a passer by who
heard a strange noise Last Friday Night
the victim looked like he was chopped by
an Axe and blood was everywhere the
police sealed off the scenes and
investigated but they have not found any
clues or witnesses that could explain
what happened
some people have suggested that this
incident may be linked to the urban
legend of
te
te tick tick a ghost of a woman who was
cut in half by a train and now haunts
the station areas she moves by dragging
her upper body with her hands and making
a Ticky Ticky sound and cuts anyone who
sees her in half with a scye or a sickle
however the police have not confirmed
this rumor and are still searching for
the truth they have asked the public to
state
I don't know if you guys have been
following distractable but my light is
haunted and it has been it has been
haunted for quite some
time I've tried to fix it and there's
nothing I can do about it so we're just
going to live with it however the police
have not confirmed this rumor and are
still searching for the truth they have
asked the public to stay calm and alert
and to report any suspicious activity or
information to
them is a syban legend res terrified all
right it's probably nothing this is
unbelievable how could this happen I
don't
know I oh reminder get
groceries almost forgot to pick up some
groceries but I got all the food I need
right here I got everything I could po
oh it's a fan I thought it was something
else I've got everything I could
possibly want a
bed three
pillows a
lamp something behind my curtain the
infinite void of nothingness that face
that's going to jump out at me right oh
I almost missed
it h everything I could possibly
want get out oh wait I have to bring the
shopping
list is that the shopping list
[Music]
hello huh
oh I see ah
milk milk olive oil white rice instant
Ramen cereal and tea bag snack snacks
dish soap okay let's
go
great this is
good
oh oh
I suppose that's fine nothing really
weird about that oh I can't go that way
I didn't want to go that way anyway I
think I saw the convenience tour over
this way what is it with Japanese games
horror games and convenience stores I
always found convenience stores to be
comforting and
relaxing and slightly murderous but
that's part of the charm that's the
reason why you go
the thrill of it otherwise life would be
very boring this don't seem like
Japan given the American signage or
English signage anyway maybe some Latin
based
language Okie doie
then did that oh I see have you guys
ever noticed that happening in real life
that happens a lot for
me
that was a delayed
footstep usually I think I'm fooling
myself but I'm only
[Applause]
almost I'm almost positive I heard
multiple footsteps there
okay
hello all right tea bags is that even on
my list oh all
right whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa all right
thank you white rice yep that was on
there milk milk olive oil white white
rice white rice and ramen cereal and tea
bag snacks dish soap milk milk olive oil
white rice in Ramen instant
Ramen cereal and tea bag snack snack
snacks dish soap okay freaking
High why are you following
me don't need tell
me
I don't know if this is helping still
need to get groceries listen I don't
care who you is if some old lady comes
up to you in the middle of the night
doesn't matter if you're in a store or
if you're in the middle of the woods if
an old lady comes up you and tells you
to run you run you don't think about it
you don't need to think about it the
wisdom in that old lady even if it's an
eldrich being there's a lot of years
there a lot of wisdom you don't question
it they know better you run and that's
it you don't need to think there's no
thinking
[Music]
involved
for milk milk lemonade
Round the Corner fudge is
made milk milk olive oil white rice
instant
Ramen cereal and tea bags snacks snacks
snacks dish
soap dish soap
okay let's just get them in order where
is my
milk milk milk
milk
milk milk
milk milk nope all right
milk all whatever
cereal
okay what do you olive oil I do need
that but after milk I need double milk I
mean need I need two jugs of
milk snacks snacks snacks I
need big old
milk milk why are you unrefrigerated why
do you seem to be in the shampoo section
whatever milk milk and instant Ramen
Ramen Tada okay thank
you
ma'am
ma'
ma'am let out the possibilities of what
could happen she's in the
bathroom she got
murdered she's hiding under the counter
waiting for me to uh Le suspect
it
or the
rapture
I'm going to guess the bathroom hey you
on the
toilet all right well I'll just close
that okay I'mma leave
now don't mind
me oh mind me all right fine I need to
settle the bill what's stopping me from
running
though
do I do I need to do I do I need
to what if I just go home what's
stopping me what's stopping me from
going
home
fine that's fine so over under on the
cashier being cut in half in the back
room
here
where is the wait where I can't even get
to the back
area
hello
hello ah yeah of course I go in the back
way this is a good
idea oh I can't even climb hi for some
reason this is what I have to do
hello
hi I'm sorry I can just settle my
bill do
I oh I thought he said wait here
isn't
whoa do you hear that
all okay it's perfectly normal
occurrence all
right well that was
weird sure did oh oh my God are you
okay are you all right
that doesn't look
good I know what's wrong with it ain't
got no gas in it you okay you dead what
happened to you and how in half are you
cut anybody no one can question this all
right I'll wait
inside hello did you
notice
see everything's
fine that wasn't everything but all
right
okay what's wrong with that old
lady
thanks okie dokie then I'm done here
that
took that took a lot longer than I
okay oh
no I'd recognize that sound
anywhere
oh
no is it out or in is it
in is that come from the
in is that on the
in is that an in
noise oh
no I don't know why I think peeping up
over the thing is going to help oh no oh
no
oh
okay oh yeah this is good I'm going to
open that door I'm going to open it I'm
here I
go all right if I have a running start
I'll be
fine oh
that's nice oh that's
great
H okay good
I'm
happy nope oh
right what what
oh he oh God
oh my God oh my God where what who where
hi
hello oh
god
oh oh God oh my God oh my God is that
the pitter patter oh my
God
I told you my life was
hunted oh that synced up too nicely with
the
music oh my
God I saw all of
that I'm going to be scarred for life
I'll never be able to purge that from my
memories if I have them for much longer
well let's see if it works for
me oh I'm fine I will
run
oh you know what I won't
run I'm just going to calmly walk
back nothing can get me cuz running is
what got that lady
killed honestly I don't know why she had
to sprint out like
that everything is fine
I thought I was dead I thought I was
dead oh my
God Mi my May me
me oh my wasn't that
nice
okay great one of two huh well you know
yeah let's let's just continue we don't
need to repeat all that stuff I bet the
truest way to
win is to not play at all
oh
hey come here you H oh all right
man I haven't jumped that hard in a long
time that jumped so hard my arm hurts
not like heart attack like I jolted
back I'm good
ah
nice a
piab a piab hi Oh Where Are You
stabbing
H
he we okay I'm not scared scared anymore
I'm not scared of
you I ain't afraid of you all I got to
do is wait
here I'd like to think that's not the
pitter patter of footsteps but it's just
someone just cranking one out real fast
and just short stuttering
bursts man okay that didn't work out
well for her but what if I go counter oh
wouldn't the counter be open okay it's
fine probably so what I need to do is
not do that I'm going around I'm going
this way I'm too smart for the TIY
TIY I knew it this is the
answer
hello this is what it's all about oh God
I'm in
danger
where's the light oh my
God this is fine why didn't that lady
take this car key with her I
wonder that's
fine oh I'm dead I'm so dead I'm a dead
man
[Applause]
you can't cut a car in
[Music]
half damn Get Wrecked all right cool
good
um oh yeah you are dead
maybe okay that was tiki Tiki moonlint
dread that was good I like that video
[Music]
over
is